et ô toi là-bas taf a vu la tête que tu
as acquis ses 25 ans était jeune
personne je suis sur une fois de plus
messieurs dames
je ne sais pas si vous voyez ce qui se
passe sur cette chaîne youtube mais nous
nous en portons dans des histoires pas
dante [ __ ] les deux dernières vidéos
ces deux mecs qui meurt en faisant du
sport extrême et des gens qui ont vécu
des trucs horribles
qu'est ce qui nous a pris on est tombé à
ce point dans le sensationnel en vrai
j'adore faire laisserait d'horreur
j'adore raconter l'histoire j'adore tous
ces trucs là mais aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de faire un truc vraiment vraiment good
vibes
en plus y'a la nouvelle dur confinement
qui est tombé ça fait mal au moral de
beaucoup de gens donc aujourd'hui on va
faire un truc génial on va donner de la
force à des gens il ya des gens qui la
vivent tous les soirs sur tweets ou qui
font des vidéos toute l'année depuis des
années et qui font 20 vue ou trois
viewers et ça ça me casse les couilles
d'accord c'est le jeu parce que c'est un
milieu où il ya énormément de gens etc
mais franchement ça fait chier et
j'adore envoyé de la force à ces gens là
et d'ailleurs c'est devenu des trucs que
je fais au quotidien dans l'ombre
or là y voir vidéo souvent je tombe sur
des streamer conchée pas entre 50 et 150
10 heures ce qui est déjà pas mal et je
leur offre des sols comme ça en passant
et après le repas et ça me fait trop
plaisir en fait parce que ces gens là
c'est moi il ya huit ans genre et je
pense qu'il ya huit ans j'aurais adoré
que quelqu'un fasse a donc tout à fait
ce qu'on va trouver des tarifs des
petits live de petits streamer et on va
aller leur envoyer de la force la force
qu'on va leur envoyer on va le faire via
les abonnements payants de twitch avant
ce truc là était un peu inaccessible
fallait vraiment faire des bonnes stats
et tout pour que twitch te le donne mais
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'accès c'est à dire il ya plein plein
plein de petits streamer qui ont déjà
les seuls donc on va aller les régaler
d'accord on va aller dans la catégorie
jazz jacking c'est juste des gens qui
parlent tranquillement avec leur chat
je pense que c'est pas mal moi y'a
quelqu'un qui regarde mon ce raid aussi
je dis je tombe sur quelqu'un
attendez attendez avoir regardé on va
savonner wesh squeeze nas pas le vrai
quand même mais c'est pas tout seul
what the fuck merci tu regarde la vidéo
merci à chiens franchement si ça fait
trop plaisir de voir ici vraiment je
mens et voilà c'est le mondial et je
vais le dire je tournais une vidéo tu as
6 secondes pour donner envie aux gens de
venir s'abonner à sa chaîne
c'est parti et ben écoute les p'tits
potes g stream tous les soirs de 20h30 à
minuit de la scène en gros n'hésitez pas
à venir vous faut la machine on fait
plein de jeu différent chaque soir et
voilà c'est à peu près tout ce qu'ils
avaient à dire là je suis au lit comme
parce que c'est halloween
j'avais pas déguisement d'halloween je
n'avais pas prévu d'être là ce soir
et voilà c'est oui bravo bravo voilà
podium c'est oui allait elle pense et
moi sommes allés directement on y va
voilà
oui merci situera la s'emballe j'adore
et à tous les sens j'essaye de bien
m'habiller tout le soir au champ [ __ ]
de vie quand vient le squeeze elle est
géniale
la mise en bouche de cette vidéo assez
incroyable bref aller alors égale à
d'autres genres allons payer les autres
gens c'est parti tu penses quoi de ma
des coûts et mon costume faux lui répond
on attendait il est sans réponse depuis
deux à trois heures bien ça vaut
clairement pas celui que j'avais cette
année pour halloween mais bien
franchement le costume lui lâche 1,7
direct un vieux vous attendez une
seconde j'ai l'impression d'être enfermé
en spéléologie la tête vers le goff et
d'ailleurs mon frère qui essayent de
tirer des jambes
elle est très foncées comme et la vidéo
elle est très fort ah les intrigues
amoureuses tu prend directement t20
sable on n'en parle plus hé les gars ya
un vrai effort de décor est tous là
quand même
il mérite en vrai je peux le faire
suivre enfin que 120 que que c'est un
être humain normal parce qu'il doit en
avoir marre qu'on le prenne pour pour
quelqu'un de paranormal
j'adore continu je te plaît continuez en
tout cas merci beaucoup continuer d'être
passionné tu peux pas m'entendre
il entendra que en voyant la vidéo ça
fait cinq ans que je fais des stream
dans mon petit coin je raconterai ça un
monfils plus tard squeeze quand il
regarde raté vidéo juste une boîte en
2000 il a offert 20 sur ma chaise et un
futur abonné de gagner allez hop claude
qui d'autre qui dot haut mais les gens y
regarder ce raid pour à l'origine c'est
trop toujours écouté aujourd'hui je vous
parlais un peu de trucs incroyables
attendait venait avant que je me montre
qu'est ce qu'elle va dire ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est qu'on n'est pas
tous sensibles
l'intro l'a fait chier elle va avancer
l'intro l'a fait chier tient le coup et
la gameuse atelier maquillage halloween
au c'est mignon c'est quoi les costumes
là ça j'adore ça j'adore les cornes bas
à alger le montrent une fois plus les
soit rentabilisée et on leur vin c'est
pour qu'elles soient remboursées des
produits pour le make up
merci c'est très gentil
[Musique]
elle s'emballe et oui c'est génial
j'adore c'est le vrai haut un nouveau
make-up aux îles et bien on lâche un
seul directement mais là on va passer en
fait non merci pour ton scène bella le
même pseudo que mais non mais c'est pas
le vrai jour tu t'es fait pirater c'est
pas beau c'est que tout ça sur mon ami
ben écoute bienvenue à toi tu comment
merci tu rigoles top spin tv à la tête
qui m'a vue sur esport jones et ce à un
fonds de la vue sur ea sports john je
suis désolé mais non je sais pas c'est
quoi mais mon mec qui connaît pas ce
coup ci alors quoi comment ça tu lui a
pas parlé de ma chaîne civile et ses
abonnés un peu je suis même pas un jaune
à toi excuses et je crois que quoi ça
[ __ ] je me fous du sang partout
j'avais oublié que j'avais du sang
machaie crochet je leur ai dit de passer
une bonne soirée mais quand même qu'elle
disait à son mec de s'abonner go alors
je fais même jamais de poids du corps
franchement là c'est un seul pour la
moustache
honnêtement c'est un seul pour la
merci à toi
oh ils sont aux noms ils sont adorables
ils font un concert ils sont adorables
ces informations ambiance
[Musique]
mais il faut que tu le sens des quelques
heures sa bonne vision adorable jusqu'au
bout attendez je veux pareil merci merci
cherche à chaud alors puisqu'on vous y
s'est abonnée au niveau 1
et bien merci squeeze pour l'abonnement
au niveau 1 merci merci
la chanson je ne sais pas si c'est le 7
mai les ivresses couiza on lui passe le
bonjour
j'espère que ça se passe bien pour
sauver la chanson si c'est le cas mais
j'ai pas eu la chance on y en a plein
d'autres s'inquiètent
si jamais tu veux voilà faire des
requêtes à écouter non invités de marque
y en avant et à août en appâtant dernier
album un jeu on pêche de l'est pas
encore
chétôt will adorable je me suis sauf
direct à toi toi tu attends mais c'est
squeeze la mondiale moi ça fait
extrêmement plaisir parce que je te suis
depuis très longtemps tu es un exemple
pour moi parce que j'ai envie d'être
streamer et c'est grâce à toi mais non
j'espère que tu vas bien
bon je vais j'y allais vous savez que je
dansais moi je dis tu aimerais tu acheté
koala niveau matériel gênante parce que
moi à son âge galères et avoir un bon pc
et ce qu'il faut franchement j'ai
beaucoup de choses à acheter mais
j'aimerais trop m'acheter un micro de de
bâtard genre un micro mais tu vois le
micro genre tu entends toutefois
extrêmement cher est légal et garazi les
gars je veux qu'il laisse au micro je
veux qu'il soit content j'étais occasion
de régal joué que 50 ans il est trop
gentil
et voilà c'est toi tu m'as d'acheter
tout micro ou p o
tu feras les stream encore meilleur
wouah ya des fréquences dans cette fois
que je ne connais pas je vais pas bien
je vais pas bien du tout je vais pas
tant merci squeeze pour ce que tu viens
de faire c'est incroyable derrière mon
vieux tu fasses ça t'aidera en soin de
toi cetto a tué mon peuple
les gardes ont baissé a besoin de dire à
quel point on aider
exemple de fou pour les plus jeunes en
fait qui ont plus besoin de modèles que
les gens plus vieux on ne sait tu vois
on ne sait dans l'inconscient qui a
beaucoup de gens qui adorent les
youtuber et qui veut devenir comme eux
mais là s'en rendre compte comme ça en
voyant qu'un jeune parler tous c'est
vraiment impressionnant je trouve en
tout cas chez total quoi jeter ton micro
offrir au régal toi continue et prend du
plaisir c'est le plus important
la suite benson aires où il a bien
soigné sa présentation ben allez hop
le som i les partitions même directement
wax squeeze comment ça va c'est pas le
vrai messie alors le gade moi toi les
histoires d'horreur là ça dit quoi
bienvenue alors on va raconter des
histoires d'horreur ce soir des piétons
est d'accord vraiment je te conseille de
rester de rester jusqu'au bout parce que
on a une histoire la dernière histoire
elle est exceptionnelle pita cette gerbe
au youtube heures vous avez vu il a
dialogué milk dû rester jusqu'à la fin
vraiment la fin c'est incroyable ce qui
se passe d'ailleurs rester alors jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie donc c'est la fin cinq
croit pas on lui offre ses vins se bat
lui aussi il prend ses mains ce ballet
op la merci beaucoup mais c'est adorable
merci énormément mais je t'en prie frère
on est passionné de voir tous les deux
mais aussi ses adorables en tout cas
j'espère que tu passes une excellente
soirée d'halloween et tu aura passé une
excellente à nos côtés je te le promets
les gars je suis à deux doigts d'arrêter
la vidéo de regarder son live je suis
désolé mais là-haut pas mal son make-up
d'halloween par rhône elle le fait à
23h42 le jour j c'est un peu tard non
je suis méchant voilà directement cc
c'est parti comme ça
pardon gg le make up ses propres il est
vraiment bien [ __ ] mais tu refais ma
soirée
bonne continuation pas l'api merci
beaucoup chao bonal oui tout ce que tu
veux
merci sur est ok on est sur la chaîne de
poli aux annonces j'arrive quand je
décroche le n'est pas de chance tu
prends tes dessins toi et ta sympathie
naturelle la cie squeeze il est gentil
lui aussi mais quelle gentillesse en
rush de l'epad
non juste une question hyper sérieuses
commencent à arriver sur le live quand
je suis arrivé je me baladais dans la
catégorie jazz chat et j'ai vu des locks
magnifique alors j'ai cliqué et nous
voilà réunis tous les deux je le veux la
durenque atterri ce dossier je m'écoute
l'orgueil et samba de fait qu ils disent
faire on veut jouer tu casses les
couilles avec ton squeeze de merde alors
ce jeu là [ __ ] alors nintendo 64
là et là toi c'est un jeu star fox a il
fait du rétro enfin machin 1080 c'était
un jeu de snowboard qui est qu'ils
avaient sorti n'ont rien d'un game cube
aussi il ya une belle collection est
venu là vous êtes sûrs comme ça il a
grandi sa collection car mon frère au
real toi attend quoi
c'est quoi ça mais qui secoue aussi
offert fin symphonie pour a grandi à ta
collection attend qu'ils entendent se
passer là merci beaucoup mais désolé
mais je t'en prie flou mais c'est trop
bientôt faire un seul pas tous les
atouts les gens qui regardent la chaîne
fois will hassett du huard donc du coup
ça va faire un tabac s'en ressent dès
janvier comme c'est probable
à écouter tous ceux qui aiment le délai
rétro moi c'est pas mes gars mon délire
mais je sais qu'il ya plein de
passionnés là qui traînent sur mes
vidéos qui kiffe les jeux rétro passé
voir son cyrus les gars il a une super
collection et les alertes icône est allé
on lui envoie la force à qui on paye la
force encore vrai j'ai encore envie
d'envoyer un petit peu au yen activités
monial en live regardez-moi ça non ce ne
soit pas de la poste nous sommes
maintenant à ce que l'esprit qu'est
m'asseoir mais [ __ ] il est génial
[ __ ] on vient trouver la perle rare et
le crozes chansons paillardes québécoise
activités manuelles modèle on y va
la france est son seul suis là pour moi
why not
il ya une chanson québécoise les gars je
suis ému attendent maintenant clan donc
domaine du bruit pour le cabba et mercy
school d'inhumaine tabarnak d'accord les
sols ah oui c'est ça que je voulais et
j'ai eu chaud mais pas grand chose ce
docu les prochains mois je m'étais pas
chocolat chercher justement y voit
simplement bon et les québécois je vous
aime
d'accord même sans l'accent l'accent
vont encore plus sympathique mais même
sans l'accent vous êtes trop sympa voilà
regardez moi les deux frérots alors
qu'il faut apparemment le pire la vie de
france excusez moi les gars est un bijou
en forme ils montrent pas l'écran mais
fait un effort l'égard de voir le jeu
s'inspire dame de france
on a prévenu ses lieutenants qui
contient cette année et je le fais
engueuler haut
ouais faut voir à l'eau voilà ils
prennent leur surf
les quelque chose et moi ça m'est bien
on va proposer un gameplay président et
là je vois bien faire quelque chose
voilà voilà ce qu'on veut à l'égard de
la transition moi non je fais pression
comme ça se faisait la vaisselle non
mais arrêtez vos cadeaux de transition
j'ai pas lu mon traîneau commencé à
temps c'est quoi cette transition c'est
qu'en échange de seine sur la ville se
passe un truc mais je vais voir quoi
expliquer il y avait eu un allié aussi
moi j'en fais de mon mieux mais ça peut
le fallait et il va souvent ils peuvent
souvent ça fait qu'on est moins bien on
ne ferait pas même outil de transition
quand il revient de vassy frais au monde
transition de rincon et son palais avec
un petit dingana tôt transition réelle
et j'ai tout donné on attend
non ça y est enfin arrêté j'ai résidé
gars la prochaine fois que je reviens la
transition doit être folle moi si tu
peux revenir d'ici six mois
je reviens dans six mois vous les gars
je le notais premier mais je vous jure
le 1er mai sur un star on va voir quelle
est la nouvelle transition de leurs
chaînes premier bon les amis je pense
que ça a assez duré deux heures et demie
avec le montage de clément et on n'a pas
vu le temps passe il mais j'aurais pu
continuer c'était archicool à faire pour
pas qu'on oublie les formats good vibes
comme celui ci comme les sabres édité
tous ils font beaucoup de bien surtout
en ce moment vu la période que traverse
bref un gros bisou aussi à tous les
streamer quittant la soirée dont je suis
pas passé sur le live ya vraiment plein
de gens qui font du contenu et sur
twitter et sur youtube et sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui ont très peu de
gens qui les suivent et qui pourtant
continuent de se donner les moyens parce
que c'est leur passion et moi ça je
trouve ça trop beau je vous souhaite le
meilleur chers collègues le best dans
votre carrière
et puis quoi ja tous pour pour se re
confinement et cette période bizarre
restons soudés envoyons-nous de l'amour
plutôt que de la haine je suis en train
de faire une morale nul à celle là les
gars c'est dur bref merci a vous de me
regarder la vidéo sur que vous a plu et
on fera peut-être format si vous a plu
se trouvait la force on leur fera
sûrement passé une merveilleuse soirée
journée peu importe a très vite
[Musique]
transition réalité